[Music]
the fury in France on this Friday night
protests and violence over a teen's
death at the hands of police will calls
for calm be answered as authorities make
hundreds of arrests
more setbacks by the U.S Supreme Court
why there are growing fears it's
enabling discrimination after its latest
ruling targets gay rights
a BC Town's somber anniversary Hal
Linton is still picking up the pieces
two years after The Inferno that took
everything
finding Pride on the Prairies one of my
hopes is that one day everyone here can
exist can be themselves the efforts to
help lgbtq2 plus people fight Prejudice
in small town Alberta
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
heavy rioting in France has prompted
president Emmanuel macron to ask parents
to keep their teenagers indoors tonight
as the country braces for what could be
another round of violence protests have
spread across the country since the
Fatal police shooting of a 17-year-old
since then some 45 thousand police
officers have been deployed to try and
restore order
875 arrests were made on Thursday night
alone although officers are the source
of much of the anger French police
unions are pushing back telling the
government they are at War as France
Burns macron is also taking aim at
social media companies saying they're
fueling the rioting on the streets
Redmond Shannon has tonight's top story
on the desperate attempts to stop the
escalating unrest
[Applause]
Friday there was no sign of calm on many
of the streets of France just more
violence and looting hogging attention
from other more peaceful protests
all of them spreading further from the
Paris suburb where on Tuesday police
shot and killed a 17-year-old known as
nael president Emmanuel macroe left an
EU Summit in Brussels early to hold a
crisis meeting in Paris
he said parents need to take
responsibility and keep their teens off
the streets
also asking some social media platforms
to remove videos of looting and extreme
violence
macron says they only encourage copycat
Behavior his interior Minister has asked
regions to ban the sale of fireworks and
gas cans all bosses and streetcars have
stopped for the night too measures that
are unlikely to quell the anger toward
police and nothing much has changed
despite all the talk of Reform despite
all of the promises not much has changed
echoing the black lives matter protests
of 2020 activists say visible minorities
are the victims of too many deaths
involving French police Beyond
institutional racism French policing has
always had the tendency to be more
apparent compared to some of the other
some of its neighbors in Europe the
officer charged with the killing has
issued an apology to Nile's family his
lawyer argues The Killing was not
intentional but police unions are not
holding out any olive branches on
Tuesday a smaller Union tweeted Bravo to
our colleagues who opened fire on a 17
year old criminal its account has since
been suspended and on Friday a major
police Union said its officers are now
at war against what it calls hordes of
savages threatening a resistance unless
police get more support macron's
government now appears to be stocked
between protesters and police both of
whom say they are not art being listened
to Redmond Shannon Global News London
and the federal government is urging
Canadian travelers to France to exercise
a high degree of caution due to the
elevated threat of terrorism with
further demonstrations planned officials
say there is a risk even peaceful
demonstrations can turn violent at any
time
the U.S Supreme Court has rolled back
anti-discrimination laws for lgbtq2 plus
Americans and potentially other minority
groups the ruling centered around a
Christian web designer who wanted to
refuse service to same-sex couples on
religious grounds as Jackson prosco
reports legal experts warned the Court's
decision could take the U.S back to a
time where businesses had the right to
refuse service to some
though she has never created websites
for weddings Colorado web designer Lori
Smith went to the U.S Supreme Court to
fight the hypothetical arguing she
should be protected from ever having to
make web pages for same-sex ceremonies
while being able to advertise her
refusal to serve certain clients whether
your views on marriage are similar to
mine or perhaps different nobody should
be forced to create a message that goes
against his or her convictions the
conservative leaning Court agreed by a
six to three margin it pierced
Colorado's anti-discrimination law
saying Smith has a right to free speech
and cannot be forced to create messages
she does not believe it is clear this
decision is not limited to one group
lgbtq individuals it's not limited to
one type of expressive service a website
conservatives call it a clear win for
Religious Freedom opponents fear the
court has legalized widespread
discrimination in a throwback to a dark
time in American history you could put
aside line on the front door that says
same-sex married people shall not apply
are there any number of things people
may believe
about the sinfulness of their potential
customers that would lead them to want
to turn them away the court put few
guard rails on the type of business or
the type of Legally objectionable
grounds for discrimination a slippery
slope I think there are lots of
companies that can claim to have
expressive elements to their goods and
services
five years ago the Court ruled narrowly
in favor of a Colorado Baker who refused
to create a wedding cake for a gay
couple only now has it undone
anti-discrimination Protections in law
part of a recent trend of rolling back
rights including access to abortion I
think we're seeing threats to democracy
in a lot of the Court's decisions as the
court signals its willingness to revisit
established rights there is concern that
other key rulings will soon be tested
including the legality of same-sex
marriage in the United States
need to okay Jackson prosco in
Washington thanks
and in another major case the U.S
Supreme Court has blocked President Joe
Biden's plan to forgive 430 billion
dollars U.S in student loan debt in a
six to three decision favoring
conservative leading States the Court
ruled it's an overreach of authority the
plan was one of Biden's campaign
promises and would have benefited up to
43 million Americans Biden pledges to
move forward with a different student
debt relief plan
in Ottawa there is Fallout over two Tech
Giants plans to block Canadian news meta
and Google are pushing back on the
federal government's attempt to help the
struggling media industry in Canada
Mackenzie gray reports on the new
regulations and how the deadlock might
end
ing out what's happening in your
community could soon get a little harder
with Facebook Instagram and Google all
saying they won't post Canadian news
this is really important not just for
the news industry but for democracy for
our country at issue the recently passed
online news act which will Force tech
Giants to cut deals with media
publishers for sharing and directing
users to online news content
parliamentary budget officer estimates
it would cost meta in Google roughly 300
million dollars annually the Silicon
Valley Giants won't play ball Google
saying the plan creates uncertainty for
our products and exposes us to uncapped
Financial liability the company
concerned it could cut into the 5.8
billion in Revenue they made in Canada
last year this is a very lucrative
market for them you know they dominate
the digital ad market and folks who
consume news content are good users the
crtc will soon start consultations on
the specific regulations under the act
and until the new rules are in place
Google and meta won't block Canadian
content but it's not just the tech
giants that are concerned many smaller
news organizations want to make sure
they're compensated properly when the
regulations are put in place Independent
Media has to really is going to have to
really fight to be sure that we do get a
proportional share of the funding meta
and Google block news for nearly a week
in Australia when Canberra brought in
similar online news laws but they did
reach a deal California is now
considering comparable legislation and
experts believe that's impacting the
tech Giants choices here in Canada
there's no doubt that what happens in
one country is seen by those Tech Giants
as precedent and or pattern for other
countries despite potential lost Revenue
Canadian media organizations including
Global News will continue to publish
journalism every single day nephew even
if it's not on Google
all right Mackenzie gray in Ottawa
thanks Mackenzie
both Toronto and Montreal once again
cracked the top five cities with the
worst air quality in the world today
special weather statements are in place
for much of Quebec and Southern Ontario
as officials urge people to reduce their
exposure to the haze as much as possible
although some rain and thunderstorms are
forecast in the region tonight the smoke
is expected to linger well into tomorrow
as hundreds of wildfires burn across the
country one BC Community is marking two
years since their town was destroyed by
wildfire
there was a moment of reflection and
hope in Linton today as people gather to
Mark the difficult day videographer
Darren twiss and I traveled to Linton
earlier this week to get a sense of how
some residents living in the few
remaining homes are coping
you miss our property I miss it a lot
Eric Pickard and Marlene Charlie are
visiting the still empty plot of land
where their home stood we got our house
in 1986.
up until two years ago when it burned in
the devastating fire that tore through
Linton BC not long after Eric filmed
this video important stuff and that was
I grabbed two pictures
she grabbed some and that was it we were
out the door we just try to forget it
and remember the June 30th is our
daughter's birthday since then they've
lived in temporary housing they have
insurance but are waiting for the
go-ahead to start rebuilding their house
I appreciate what the government's done
I really do but we have to make it move
faster even here at work we don't have
landlines yet Laverne Henry and Nina
sedorchuk say some residents lost hope
of returning home and have started to
build lives elsewhere to me it's sad
because there's been a few already that
are saying that they're not coming back
home the village of Linton was very
important for the surrounding area
because it's a meeting point of all the
surrounding communities within our
nation linton's mayor says even the
local bylaws which weren't backed up
electronically have to be Rewritten she
says it will likely be another few years
for a full community rebuild and
navigating that process is challenging
it doesn't work for small communities we
don't have the capacity to to manage a
recovery on our own the mayor has been
careful not to give specific timelines
but she says she hopes streets like this
one will be lined with some basement
foundations for homes by the end of this
summer as a village now we are trying to
shift from recovery to rebuild and I
think that's a strong message and
residents have noticed some of the signs
of Hope in recent days including the
reopening of the sidewalk there's just
all of these things that are having no
progress so something as small as a
security fence keeping us off our
properties just being moved back a
little is really huge the ripple effect
of what happened two years ago is still
being felt remember looking at the fire
as Eric and Marlene find comfort in the
one sentimental piece of their property
that survived this rose bush remember
that it can happen to you residents
marking the somber anniversary say they
just hope their story and ongoing
struggle won't be for forgotten
also in BC the search for a missing
teenager who spent two nights lost in
the woods has ended with good news
sixteen-year-old Esther Wang got lost
hiking with friends in Golden Ears Park
on Tuesday a huge search was launched
and last night as Darkness fell Esther
emerged but it wasn't the search teams
who tracked her down it turns out she
found her own way out
yes there's obviously a very determined
young lady whereas there was in the
steepness of that train in some
situations you end up being in a
location where once you go down it's
very difficult to get back up again
unhazardous as well
police say the first people Esther saw
were her parents waiting in the parking
lot other than some mosquito bites she
is unharmed
complicated feelings for Canada day
coming up the evolving sentiment towards
celebrating the country's birthday
Canada day is the Kickstart to summer
for many people across the country but
exclusive new polling for Global News
suggests overall feelings towards a
national holiday are changing according
to ipsis nearly half of Canadians are
changing the way they commemorate July
1st compared to five years ago as Eric
Sorensen reports pride in our national
identity is also seeing a shift
Laura Jimenez moved here 10 years ago
and has no complaints about Canada I
can't say I feel very proud to be part
of this many are unabashedly proud I
love this country I love the immigration
I love
that's the way it's evolving but how
people feel is evolving too the
celebrations that at one time fully
accepted Canada's Colonial past now come
with more reflection we have to
acknowledge that the times when we fall
short of our goals and objectives 42
percent of Canadians say their feeling
of pride has changed in the last five
years 21 feel more proud 21 less the
change is mostly generational
Millennials and and gen Zed much more
likely to be re-examining uh their
Canadian identity in their relationship
to Canada uh Boomers much more likely to
be maintaining the status quo while
recent events or politics may have
caused some Canadians to feel
differently about their pride in this
country for others it's Canada's long
history that brings about those
questions
the mistreatment of indigenous people
that was long ignored has prompted many
to view Canada's identity through a
different prism today Canadians really
have to re-examine what they're
celebrating the Privileges that
Canadians have
um for over for the last 150 years plus
comes at the sacrifice to indigenous
peoples the ipso survey found there is
growing awareness 39 percent of
Canadians are more likely to learn about
indigenous history than five years ago
and it jumps to close to half among
young Canadians Millennials and gen Z
there's much more awareness now and I I
think it's really shameful that you know
that was we're not part of our education
that there is greater sensitivity among
young people suggests that Canadians
sense of themselves will continue to
evolve while many Still Believe on
balance it's a good country I don't
think we need to feel bad every day even
though if it's Canada day so I think we
can still celebrate you Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto
Port workers on Canada's West Coast
serve strike notice the potential
economic impact ahead
experts are warning of major damage
looming for Canada's economy as we inch
closer to the strike deadline for
thousands of poor workers in BC some 7
400 workers are set to walk off the job
tomorrow morning if no deal is reached
tonight the job action would affect more
than 30 ports in the province including
those in Vancouver and in Prince Rupert
both pivotal for Canadian trade some 800
million dollars worth of goods flow
through BC ports every day
Hollywood actors are on the verge of
joining screenwriters in a second labor
strike this summer which could have
major implications on the film industry
studios are racing against a midnight
deadline to reach a deal with the Union
representing actors which represents 160
thousands of them including artists a
strike would turn up the heat on
Hollywood already grappling with a
nearly two-month work stoppage by The
Writer's Guild of America A-list actors
say they're ready to walk off the job if
negotiators can't reach a deal on pay
and the use of artificial intelligence
the entertainment world is mourning the
loss of award-winning actor Alan Arkin
you are the most beautiful girl in the
whole world
Arkin who won an Oscar for his
supporting role in Little Miss Sunshine
is being remembered as a uniquely
talented force of nature the actor was
known for his deadpan comic timing he
became famous appearing in films like
the Russians are coming the Russians are
coming and the heart is a Lonely Hunter
which earned him best actor nominations
Alan Arkin was 89 years old
[Music]
a big heart for pride in a
minute
the lgbtq2 plus Community has been
celebrated all June for pride month
rainbow flags and parades are accepted
in most big cities but it's not always
the case in rural areas in central
Alberta the last few months have been
hard weeks after a provincial election
candidate made hateful comments about
trans youth she secured a landslide
Victory the local queer Community
experienced acts of vandalism soon after
but as Heather urac's West explains in
the little city of Lacombe the spirit of
pride is thriving
foreign
Alberta City filled with pickup trucks
and small town charm
you'll find a very colorful home
surrounded by rainbow flags that often
need replacing
[Laughter]
every time they're stolen the kickstra
family just puts out more sometimes
their friends help too the first time
they stole the big rainbow like it's
gone but we have very wonderful
neighbors who replaced it for us for
Candace kick struck it's just part of
being a mom how was the test when two of
her teenagers came out as queer the
family questioned whether or not they
should stay the comb is a little city
with well-established conservative
values I'm out at school kind of I'm not
very loud at school just because it's
not fantastic all the time
for Jonathan lesscombe it hasn't always
been the easiest place to be gay I only
came out in 2021 because of the place I
live when I was young people shouted the
epsler down the street they shouted you
were kicked out of businesses you were
you were looked at with utter disgusts
because of the way you dress
only out
Bounder and executive director of
lacombe's first Pride Society one of my
hopes is that one day again that
everyone here can exist can be
themselves can feel loved but the last
few months have shown this community
still has a ways to go in May a
recording surfaced of the local United
Conservative Party candidate comparing
trans children to feces Jennifer Johnson
was removed from the UCP caucus but won
easily on Election Day days later the
pride display in nearby Ponoka was
vandalized Alberta RCMP say across the
province hate motivated incidents
against the lgbtq2 plus Community are on
the rise it's not a good feeling there's
just some learning that needs to be done
on their part and the spread of
misinformation is is just tremendous but
that's also why the kickstraz ultimately
decided to stay working alongside others
like lescombe to inspire Pride on the
Prairies to make Lacombe a place
everyone can truly call home
Heather York's West Global News Lacombe
Alberta
and that is global national for this
Friday I'm nitu Garcia tonight's year
Canada is Port Coquitlam BC we love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers globalnational.com thanks for
watching have a good night
[Music]
thank you